ein kleiner ort in unterfranken
hier lebt planer mit ihren eltern sie
ist 17 und einer der knapp 500.000
jugendlichen und kinder die einen
angehörigen pflegen seit neun jahren
versorgt sie ihren kranken vater
als ich acht war hat sich das dann das
erste mal wirklich bemerkbar gemacht
meine mama und ich wollten so eine
skulpturenausstellung und der papa
sollte eigentlich mit kommen und dann
ging es ihm aber nicht so gut ich dachte
okay papas erkältet oder es war winter
als nvidia kamen lag hat dann mehr oder
weniger auf dem küchenboden und hat sich
fast nicht mehr bewegt und habe
gezittert und alles mögliche und ist er
ins krankenhaus gekommen mit
nierenversagen und bei
lungenentzündungen und
seitdem also ist er
jedes jahr eigentlich mindestens drei
bis fünf mal im krankenhaus gebiet für
mehrere wochen ihren rebhan ist 54 und
unheilbar krank er leidet an chronischen
zwischen ihren es gibt gute tage wie
heute aber alleine essen machen geht
trotzdem nicht in welchen situationen
brauchen sie die wirklich dann die hilfe
von war
die hilfe brauche ich nur wenn ich bin
immer bewegen also wenn ich musste also
muskelschwäche habe aber so
richtig stehen kann so dann muss sie
halt was macht man wenn
es dann schön dich ist der blutdruck
sucht ist
aber also heute zum beispiel habe ich
kopfschmerzen und ich habe mir so viel
deshalb nenne das immer so eine unruhe
da kannst weder hinsetzt noch stehen und
danach ein ich war hier raus und das
habe ich jetzt will
und das ist so toll also wenn es so ist
dann konnten wir den einsatz
lana ist immer in bereitschaft wie viel
sie ihm helfen muss hängt von seiner
tagesform ab
ihre mutter kann die beiden erst nach
der arbeit unterstützen
weil frau ganz auf das kochen die kommen
nur so spielräume
ohne die viele arbeit von katharina
rebhan würde das geld nicht reichen
ihre tochter musste deshalb schon früh
lernen ohne sie klar zu kommen und was
im notfall zu tun war
ist der notfallplan der ihn damals bei
uns an der wand das war praktisch die
motivation dahinter wald was ist jetzt
wenn wenn du mit papa alleine zu hause
bist halt nicht so gut
wie ich mich dann verhalten soll ja ich
muss ja die 112 anrufen sagen das paar
am boden liegt oder also die situation
beschreiben die tür auf lassen für den
krankenwagen dass der lang gleich kommen
kann und halt zu nachbarn gehen um nach
hilfe zu fragen und da hat meine mama
mir noch mal die telefonnummer vom
notdienst hingeschrieben ich wusste
nicht mal was das ist aber ich wusste
ich musste anrufen aber das war so eine
kleine sicherheit wahrscheinlich nicht
erkennen dass nichts ich nicht so helfen
ja also auf jeden fall für mich klar
dass ich bewusst immer ins ball was ich
machen soll aber auf jeden fall auch für
meine mama dass sie hat auch ein
bisschen beruhigt da auf die arbeit
gehen konnte bislang zwölf war hatten
sie anspruch auf eine haushaltshilfe
das regelt die krankenkasse danach kam
niemand mehr also wir haben sehr viel
probiert wer wir sind und die stadt
gegangen wenn mir den schuh in der
schule nachgefragt jugendamt
eigentlich alles was man so irgendwie
bezieht und es geht ja im endeffekt um
das wohl von von dem kind und da
probiert natürlich auch alles aus
doch unterstützung für lana fanden sie
nirgends das jugendamt warf ihnen sogar
vor bloß eine billige babysitterin zu
suchen erzählen sie wenn das kindeswohl
nicht offensichtlich gefährdet ist
springt das jugendamt nicht ein
hilfe um die überforderung der kinder
mit den kranken eltern irgendwie
aufzufangen sehen leistungskatalog und
dünne personaldecke nicht vor für
pflegende kinder wie lana gibt es
keinerlei praktische unterstützung
lana suchte lange selbst nachhilfe weil
es nichts gab gründete sie eine eigene
website für janka ross so nennen sich
junge pflegende weltweit ein netzwerk um
sich gegenseitig zu unterstützen und
wahrgenommen zu werden
hast du wirklich damit zu kämpfen dass
ein viele menschen die ich nicht
verstehen ich sehen und du dich auch
selber nicht gesehen fühlst planus seite
hat erfolg viele melden sich bei ihr
mädchen aber auch jungs hallo ich ankara
hilfe langer rappern hallo spreche ich
mit den 1000 ghanaer die am projekt
gestartet war sie 14 das hat sich dann
ein stück für stück so aufgebaut und bei
dem e mail kontakte habe ich immer mit
gelesen weil sie ja doch noch relativ
klein auch war und zwar für mich auch
wichtig dass es einfach rechtlich
einfach eine
gewisse sicherheit auch da ist und lange
sitzung ein bisschen rein gewachsen und
viele gespräche führt sich selber und
alles wo sie weiß da fühlt sie sich
nicht sicher oder sowas dann rufe ich an
so unterschiedlich die situationen zu
hause sind die not der youngsters ist
bei allen die gleiche sie übernehmen
verantwortung in einem alter in dem sie
die fürsorge der eltern selbst am
nötigsten bräuchten
natürlich können wir jetzt keine
therapeutische beratung ersetzen das ist
ganz klar aber wir versuchen dann schon
zu vermitteln dass einfach die die
hemmschwelle gegenüber den den jugendamt
abgebaut wird versuchen da kontakte
herzustellen und versuchen einfach die
kinder dann zu unterstützen
pflegewissenschaftlerin sabine metzing
hat die erste und bisher einzige studie
zur ankaras in deutschland verfasst
demnach kommen statistisch auf eine
schulklasse bis zu zwei kinder die
pflegen das sind sechs prozent der 10
bis 18 jährigen
und eigentlich sind es noch mehr weil
die die vermeintlich nur den haushalt
machen oder sich um geschwister kümmern
gar nicht erfasst sind die
chronische krankheit führt vor allem
dazu dass sich der alltag einer familie
verändert das heißt aufgaben müssen
umverteilt werden und und es löst die
familie erst mal so für sich und das ist
auch erstmal selbstverständlich jeder
hilft mit und jeder packt an der große
hilfe bedarf ist am anfang gar nicht da
das sind kleinigkeiten die nicht mehr
gehen eltern die zum beispiel eine
multiple sklerose entwickeln verlieren
pö a pö ihre fähigkeiten feinmotorik
oder die die fähigkeit zu laufen und und
kinder sich füllen die lücken also da wo
gerade was fehlt da treten sie rein und
und kompensieren dass und deshalb haben
sie auch kein kein verständnis davon
dass sie jetzt pflegende sind sondern
sie helfen in der familie dass der
alltag weiter geht und darum geht es die
dürfen auch mal mit kochen und aufräumen
und und wenn eltern zum beispiel
sondennahrung bekommen dann finden die
das auch toll wenn sie diesen beutel
anhängen können und so und das finde ich
spricht auch gar nichts dagegen aber
wenn die eltern sonst keinen beutel
sondern kost bekommen wenn das kind das
nicht tut dann stimmt was nicht wenn die
eltern nicht
gewaschen werden wenn sie nicht von den
kindern gewaschen werden dann sind
grenzen überschritten
die expertin fordert seit langem dass es
eine staatliche institution geben müsste
die die sozialsysteme vernetzt und
gezielt hilfen anbietet eine mutter hat
mir mal gesagt ich brauche da sowas wie
bei der giftnotrufzentrale
eine nummer und da weiß ich da wird mir
geholfen und ich brauche da nicht
tagelang ich brauchte hilfe jetzt bin
wenn ich mich morgens nicht bewegen kann
und jemand mein kind zur schule bringen
muss und das haben wir nicht nein das
haben wir nicht wir brauchen eine art
ministerium oder oder ein ein träger der
die familie im blick hat und wir haben
beim bei der jugendhilfe die gucken nur
auf die kinder und jugendlichen die
krankenkassen oder das
gesundheitsministerium cook nur auf die
erkrankte person aber wir haben
niemanden der wirklich sagt ich guck auf
system- und und ich nehme die
komplexität der situation war und
versuche darauf eine antwort zu finden
jetzt machen wir die erfahrung dass sie
sich gegenseitig die verantwortung
zuschieben und ich sage nein das ist
aufgabe der jugendhilfe nein das ist
aufgabe des vierten
gesundheitsministeriums und so kommen
wir einfach nicht weiter die lücke im
system sei spätestens seit ihrer studie
bekannt bisher aber hat die politik kaum
reagiert das familienministerium hat
zwar die website pausen taste die jungen
pflegenden mut machen und sie
informieren soll doch was wird konkret
fürs kind getan es geht ja gar nicht
darum dass hilfe für dieses kind jetzt
organisiert wird sondern es geht ja
oftmals um die mutter um den vater um
die oma dass da eine pflegestufe
womöglich gegeben ist aber vielleicht
gar nicht eingestuft wurde ja weil man
das noch gar nicht gemacht hat und wenn
dann klar ist es die mutter ebene
bestimmten pflege grad hat dann habe ich
ja auch anspruch auf leistungen und dann
kann ich eben dafür sorgen dass jemand
in die familie kommt bei der hausarbeit
unterstützt bei der pflege unterstützt
müsste es da nicht auch speziell etwas
für die kinder geben deswegen haben wir
diese diese pausen taste mit all diesen
angeboten wo vielleicht auch
gleichgesinnte sich austauschen können
alle diese angebote gibt es jetzt gibt
die pausen taste er aber nicht unbedingt
eine praktische hilfe wie finden denn
diese jungen leute auch praktische
unterstützung ja es geht darum erstmal
aufzuzeigen du musst nicht bis an seine
grenzen gehen ja wir können dir helfen
du bist nicht alleine
ein erster schritt immerhin aber viele
brauchen praktische unterstützung vor
ort und echte entlastung an einer
berliner gemeinschaftsschule wollen sie
das jetzt versuchen hier startet das
erste deutsche schulprogramm für young
care as beratung holt sich das schulteam
aus london dort ist die dimension des
themas längst bekannt hilfsangebote sind
in ganz england erfolgreich an schulen
etabliert
das ist der name
unseres schulprogramms
und die vision für das schult programm
ist wirklich eine schulkultur zu
entwickeln die den aufbau waren
mitgefühl
auch für kate und geständnis zu
psychischer erkrankung und schulen und
schulen und lehrkräfte fördert so dass
die betroffenen kinder in der schule
besser unterstützt werden ja möchten wir
eine ag anbieten also ein gruppenangebot
hier an der schule für ihn herum und
dann war unsere frage wie wir das machen
können ohne dass quasi auf dieser ag auf
das und gruppenangeboten einstieg mal
die die hier an carroll müssen selbst
wählen ob sie in dieser gruppe
teilnehmen wollen also es muss
freiwillig sein aber es kann schon ein
angebot sein das dann auch ganz klar
sozusagen darauf hinweist dass es dafür
da ist ja ein kerl zu unterstützen ja
noch mal ein bis zwei kinder pro klasse
die zu hause angehörige pflegen die
schule will diese situation nicht länger
ignorieren wie weit greifen wir also in
das
familienleben hier rein wünscht sich
eine familie dass wir ihr
und worden oder welcher weg ist zu gehen
wenn eine familie total ab lukas auf
jeden fall auch als große chance also
auch nicht nur rein für die schule
sondern auch gesamtgesellschaftlich wenn
man hier beginnt zu sensibilisieren und
so eine ja eine sichere atmosphäre zu
schaffen dann wird sich das ja auch
immer weiter tragen und irgendwann wenn
sich das dann gefestigt hat dann
habe ich zumindest auch die hoffnung
dass sich das an der gesellschaft dann
irgendwann widerspiegeln wird wenn man
da wirklich dran bleibt und da gibt es
glaube ich eine gute chance früh
gemeinsam etwas zu starten auf mehreren
ebenen und vernetzt und miteinander wenn
das programm in berlin gut anläuft
könnte es vorbild für schulen in ganz
deutschland werden noch ist es ein
pilotprojekt
statt ausschließlich privater
initiativen bräuchten young care as
dringend zusätzlich institutionelle
unterstützung
das würde junge pflegende vilana endlich
in der gesellschaft sichtbar machen
[Musik]
wenn ich glück habe ich nächstes jahr
dann aus aber wenn papa nicht gutgeht
sich natürlich nicht aus andere andere
planen so ihr ganzes leben vorneweg aber
ich bin froh wenn nicht schon das
nächste ist nächste halbe jahr irgendwie
in übersicht ab also man muss wirklich
schauen
lana will auch während ihrer ausbildung
zur steuerfachgehilfin weiter für ihren
vater da sein sie weiß er wird nicht
mehr gesund
das problem ist möglich wenn er im
krankenhaus ist wie wir es zb 2017 2018
hatten also das waren so die beiden
schweren jahre wurde dann drei monate
lang einfach ein krankenhaus war meine
mama arbeitet und ich einfach komplett
allein im haushalt war in der zeit wo
man 13 der geburtstag den ich auch auf
die intensivstation verbracht habe und
so und ich kann mich auch daran ändern
wie oft wir im krankenhaus durch die
gänge gelaufen sind von intensivstation
rausgekommen cent richtern geweint habe
und ich mich danach auch so schuldig
gefühlt habe weil ich mir dachte okay du
kannst dich für deine mama auf einen wie
beim doch selber lana wollte ihrer
mutter nicht auch noch die eigenen
sorgen aufladen erst als sie in der
achten klasse sitzen bleibt erzählt sie
einem lehrer was los ist irgendwann
sagte zu mir nach der stunde damals ich
bin ein lehrer ich darf sowas eigentlich
nicht sagen aber ich bin stolz auf dich
und
er mein erster gedanke war sowieso bist
sowieso darfst du das nicht sagen nur
weil mein lehrer bist sagt mir dass sie
das stolz auf mich bist und im zweiten
moment habe ich vor den angefangen zu
weinen ich habe ganz ganz ganz ganz fest
geweint weil ich einfach dachte so war
endlich das ist alles was ich hören
wurde das war einfach alles einfach mal
anerkennung dass irgend was mir am
meisten gebracht hat weil einfach leute
die mich in den arm nehmen und einfach
sagen okay es ist eine schwere situation
aber du bist nicht schuld
[Musik]
solange kranken und pflegekassen nur die
patientinnen sehen für die kinder und
jugendlichen aber niemand zuständig ist
bleiben sie auf der strecke was wir
dringend brauchen ist eine institution
die für die ganze familie verantwortlich
ist denn young care as brauchen
unterstützung als kinder und als
pflegende
[Musik]